[Musica]
Buonasera
il racconto che voglio fare a tutti voi
e prendere mosse dal grande mosaico di
Alessandro che si conserva come tutti
sapete nel Museo Archeologico Nazionale
di Napoli si tratta di un'opera eccelsa
che è una copia probabilmente di età
romana di un grande dipinto di Apelle il
pittore di corte di Alessandro Magno che
dipinse in onore del re macedone quando
nel 331 avanti Cristo Alessandro si
sconterò contro Dario III codomanno di
Persia e a seguito di questa
strabiliante Vittoria riuscì ad
assoggettare per la prima volta l'Asia
alla Grecia
si tratta di un'opera straordinaria che
ci racconta un'impresa epica un'impresa
forse che ha del sovrannaturale il
giorno prima della Battaglia il re
macedone sacrificò a fobos alla paura
perché i macedoni erano 30.000 mentre le
fonti ricordano che i Persiani avessero
uno sterminato esercito circa 100.000
uomini che cosa
significa questa opera per noi questa
sera significa
sostanzialmente che se ci sono stati
personaggi come Alessandro che hanno
creduto in un sogno Ecco a volte con la
tenacia e forse anche un velo di pazzia
che lo ha connotato si possono
raggiungere dei traguardi incredibili ed
è uno spettacolo che è stato realizzato
da un regista francese in qualche anno
fa che riguardava Alessandro ha parlato
della tigre blu di Alessandro cioè
Alessandro in punto di morte Ricorda a
Babilonia E negli ultimi istanti di aver
sempre voluto seguire la tigre blu che è
un animale fantastico dell'Asia e il
quale appare a coloro che vogliono
intraprendere delle dei percorsi oltre
diciamo così la forza dell'uomo e che se
si seguono in qualche modo
consentono di arrivare veramente alle
estreme propaggini del mondo
Alessandro afferma sul letto di morte di
non
aver più visto la tigre blu il giorno in
cui l'esercito qualche tempo prima che
lui morisse a Babilonia Appunto e si
rifiutò di andare oltre l'indo Dopo
l'ultima battaglia contro poros il re
indiano che aveva questi elefanti da
guerra che erano davanti agli occhi dei
Greci dei dei mostruosi diciamo così
contendenti ecco si fermano e lui
capisce che il suo sogno è finito
Quale è la tigre blu del Museo
Archeologico Nazionale di Napoli Ecco la
nostra tigre la nostra il nostro sogno è
quello di togliere la grande menzogna
che ancora aleggia in tutti i musei
Archeologici del mondo di che cosa si
tratta si tratta sostanzialmente di una
precisa volontà di propaganda antica e
moderna che aleggia tra le opere dei
musei
vi faccio alcuni esempi tra le
propaganda Antica per esempio Noi
abbiamo delle statue straordinarie di
Guerrieri persiani inginocchiati che si
riferiscono ad un monumento celebrativo
di una vittoria dell'imperatore Augusto
che non avvenne mai Augusto dopo la
sconfitta di carne e che aveva patito
grasso 50 anni dopo patteggia con il re
persiano per riavere le insegne paga non
c'è internet quindi come dire a Roma si
può celebrare questa vittoria
presentando i persiani in ginocchio
Peccato che però qualche tempo dopo nel
120 dopo Cristo siano i Persiani invece
a realizzare un grandissimo monumento
dove si vedono gli imperatori romani in
ginocchio i nostri musei raccontano solo
un tipo di storia e per esempio
raccontano In maniera abbastanza
propagandistica il fatto che Roma si
espande in tutto il Mediterraneo che
Roma conquista la Britannia Ma nessuno
di noi si ricorda per esempio la frase
di Tacito che ricorda appunto come i
romani andando in Britannia fecero
rinunciare queste parole ad un
abitante del luogo hanno fatto un
deserto e l'hanno chiamata pace una
frase che poi sarà ripresa nella guerra
del Vietnam
Ecco questa è la propaganda antica e di
questa siamo infarciti nel museo lo
stesso mosaico di Alessandro ci parla di
una strepitosa vittoria del macedone ma
non ci parla di tutti quei persiani che
furono uccisi o delle 40.000 persiane
che furono successivamente costrette a
sposarsi con 40.000 macedoni e così via
Se poi una propaganda moderna dei musei
e cioè per esempio il fatto che tanti
oggetti siano ancora Considerati gli
scalpi di guerra pensati al Partenone
pensa del Partenone pensate per esempio
alla serie di Rosetta che è stata prima
e preda dei francesi e successivamente
dopo averlo è passata al British Museum
Allora Di cosa parla nei nostri musei
parlano di imperi antichi e parlano di
imperi presenti parlano di occidente ma
soprattutto parlano di vincitori di chi
non parlano non parlano di schiavi non
parlano di donne segregate non parlano
di Popoli vinti non c'è mai nei nostri
musei La voce dei vinti Ora però se noi
vogliamo costruire dei musei nuovi
dobbiamo fare questo salto di qualità e
come dire Riportare nel Tribunale della
Giustizia tutti quelli che giustiziano
l'hanno avuta nel mondo antico E allora
per dare giustizia agli schiavi per dare
giustizia a tutti quei popoli che sono
stati soggiogati nel tempo da Roma o da
altri imperi noi dobbiamo fare questo
sforzo di narrazione E se facciamo
questo ci accorgiamo di una cosa
Mirabile e cioè che il mondo antico non
è migliore del nostro anzi in un antico
per molti versi è stato
corso del nostro per le carneficine per
l'ingiustizie sociali per la mancanza
dei diritti di base Ecco questo è il
punto noi siamo come loro e loro sono
come noi allora se questo è Noi abbiamo
un'occasione irripetibile e cioè quella
di Non commettere gli errori che sono
stati fatti nel mondo antico imitando le
vette ed evitando gli abissi se questo
possiamo farlo allora i nuovi musei
devono parlare degli sconfitti ma
soprattutto devono essere i luoghi
dell'inclusione dove le comunità minori
per esempio della nostra città possono
ritrovare pezzi della loro storia e dove
non necessariamente noi dobbiamo imporre
la nostra storia i musei vedete anche
nel nostro codice si dice devono educare
ma educare cosa al fatto che Roma sia
fatta avanti con le armi al fatto che
come dire non c'era possibilità di
arrivare a Patti al fatto che ancora Noi
oggi siamo a pensare della sconfitta di
Teutoburgo delle due legioni di vario e
quasi si rammarichiamo scortandoci che
noi eravamo lì per portare la
distruzione Allora questo non deve
succedere più così come non deve
succedere che ad esempio in America ci
siano musei di tutti i tipi anche di
archeologia classica ma non ci siano i
musei degli indiani d'America Questo è
il punto Oggi il nuovo museo e la nostra
tigre blu è quella che vuole in qualche
modo creare una storia mondiale vuole
presentare la nostra storia ma vuole
accogliere anche la storia degli altri
noi siamo presenti con moltissime mo in
questo momento a Tokyo in Cina a New
York ma contemporaneamente accogliamo la
cultura della Cina accogliamo la cultura
del Giappone abbiamo una mostra sui
manga senza dire noi siamo meglio di voi
ma soprattutto per dire che il museo e
il luogo dove ci si confronta dove se io
guardo una storia un vaso con un
naufragio antico non posso non pensare a
il naufragio che c'è in questo momento
nel Mediterraneo dove se io come dire
parlo di un Mediterraneo che è diciamo
così a rischio di inquinamento non
possono ricordare per esempio che anche
l'uomo antico aveva iniziato a fare
disastri pensate al Libano al cielo del
Libano fu completamente desertificato
per utilizzare questo materiale questo
legno per la carpenteria Quindi da forte
rassicuriamoci non c'è stato solo Fidia
e policleto non c'è stato solo
Aristotele ma ci sono state tante
persone normali come noi tante persone
che hanno sbagliato tante persone che ci
danno coraggio perché abbiamo
un'occasione
imperdibile tramite i nuovi musei creare
luoghi non tanto dove noi dobbiamo
educare non tanto dove noi dobbiamo
ricercare Ma soprattutto dove noi
possiamo essere felici perché si può
andare al museo per essere felici e per
costruire nuovi ponti di umanità e da lì
partire per disseminarsi con messaggi
nuovi anche
digitali anche con i nuovi diciamo
linguaggi del fumetto tra i giovani in
città rigenerando i quartieri essendo
una forza nuova che esce dalla torre
d'Avorio e si assume una responsabilità
politica noi vogliamo musei dove siamo
felici Ma vogliamo musei non
politicamente corretti Ma che prendono
una posizione e cercano di favorire la
crescita di tutti i cittadini Grazie
[Applauso]